JOANNA SMITH: Hi, everybody and
welcome back to "Google+
Developers Live." I'm
Joanna Smith.
And I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer for Google+.
And today I'm being joined by
two Product Managers, Thor and
Joel, to talk about the new
Google+ Domains API.
We launched this at I/O.
We announced it
anyway, this summer.
And we're really excited because
now it's finally
publicly available.
So Joel, why don't you tell us
a little bit about why we
built this.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
Thanks, Joanna.
I'm Joel Kalmanowicz.
I'm a Product Manager
on Google Apps.
And I focus on Google+.
Now, the intersection of Google
Apps and Google+ is
enterprise social networking.
And we're really excited in this
space because we can do
things with Google+ that we
can't really do out in the
consumer public world.
Because enterprises, being
businesses and schools, use a
lot of third-party tools for
other purposes in the day to
day life of a professional.
This means we can integrate
Google+ as a social spine
across other services and not
just have to build things onto
Google+ itself.
JOANNA SMITH: Well, thanks
for joining us, Joel.
Thor, can you give us some
insight into some of the new
features that are special for
the Google+ Domains API?
THOR MITCHELL: Sure.
Hi, my name is Thor Mitchell.
I'm a Product Manager
for the Google+ API.
When we started working with
the Enterprise Team on this
API, it became clear.
There are a couple of areas
that we should focus on.
The first is Circle Management,
so creating
circles and syncing circles to,
for example, a corporate
directory, managing
people in circles.
The second was the stream, so
both understanding the way
that users within a domain are
using the stream and what
they're posting, what they're
sharing and commenting on, and
also allowing third-party
applications
to post to the stream.
JOANNA SMITH: Thanks, Thor.
So I know we just teased you
with some really cool features
that you want to get
to know how to use.
So let's go ahead and take a
look at how you can do this.
The first step, as always,
is to go to
developers.google.com/+/domains
And this is going to be your
gateway into learning
what is up.
We tried to do what we could
really do to help you out.
So we organized the entire left
navigation bar by feature
and by what you might
want to do.
So straight up, let's
get started.
And what we did here is, we
created a chart, that I think
is really fantastic.
Because it compares the existing
Google+ API to the
Google+ Domains API, and this
means that if you've already
been developing for Google,
you can see what's new and
what's different that you might
want to start exploring
right away.
And then, of course,
we have two quick
starts Java and Python.
And the best thing about these
is, they show off a different
type of authentication.
Because everybody has started
to get a grasp now of server
side OAuth authentication
where you can actually
authenticate on a user-by-user
basis.
And we have the code here
for you, to show
you how to do that.
But what's cool is, we also
now have domain-wide
delegation.
And what this means is, instead
of authenticating one
user at a time, you can actually
authenticate an app
on behalf of all of the users
within a domain at once.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: It's important
to note that this
functionality is only available
to the domain admins.
And it's exactly the same as
it works with other Google
Apps APIs, such as
the Drive API.
So this allows Google Apps
admins to be able to say, yes,
it's OK for this app to
authorize on behalf of anyone
in the domain, because they're
essentially installing a
product for their entire
systems across
their business or school.
JOANNA SMITH: Definitely,
that's exactly right.
And because this is so different
from what we've
historically offered for the
Google+ platform, we decided
to make this the main
authentication we use in our
quick start.
So if you'd like to see it
running, you can go ahead and
download that from our GitHub
repo and get started.
And then what we have is
different things that you
might want to do, different
API calls you
might want to make.
They're classic, getting
profiles, with your
people.get.
We also have managing circles.
And what we have here are
multiple ways for you to
actually make sure your
circles are all
constantly up to date.
And Thor mentioned this briefly
earlier, but you can
create circles.
You can delete circles.
You can add people or move
people, see the people that
are in a circle, see the circles
that a person has.
there are so many different
things you can do, to help
make sure that your circle
management is as easy
as it should be.
Then we have the ability
for you to read posts.
And what's really cool about
this is that, it's no longer
limited to just the posts that
have been publicly shared.
And so we've got the code
here for you to do it.
But Thor, do you want to take
a moment to explain what's
different about the
domain sharing?
THOR MITCHELL: Sure.
So when you're using the
existing public Google+ API
that we've had for a
while now, you can
authenticate as yourself.
But then, the API only offers
access to content that you've
shared publicly.
In the Google+ Domains API, as
a user in an apps domain, the
API can access any of the
content that you've shared
with any audience.
However, when you post using the
API, you can only create a
restricted post, which
is a post that
cannot leave that domain.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
So let's go ahead and take a
look at how to create a post.
And it's pretty straightforward.
All you have to do is create the
message you want to say,
create the body.
And that's going to
be the content.
And what we have here in this
Python is, we have the post
being created through an
activities.insert call.
And it's done as
a JSON object.
So you see, we sent the original
content, which is
just your message that
you want to say.
And then what we do is,
we set the sharing.
And right here, this one is
being shared with the domain.
And then, of course, we set
the domain restricted
parameter to True.
This has to be the case on every
single call you make to
activities.insert.
Or else it's going to fail
because you cannot post beyond
your domain.
And then, also, on this page,
we have how to share to a
specific circle, how to
share to a person,
how to write a comment.
But even cooler, you'll
see on the left now.
We show you how to attach URLs,
how to attach media, if
you want to attach a photo or a
video, and also how to do a
reshare programmatically.
So there's a lot for you
to discover here at
developers.googl
e.com/+/domains.
Let's go ahead and take
a step back and look
at the bigger picture.
We talked about some of the
really cool features in the
new API calls.
But maybe we should discuss
some of the
use cases for them.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: So as I said
before, one of the main
motivations we had for
developing this is because, in
the enterprise space, for
businesses and schools,
usually you're users and you
admins are already making use
of a lot of third-party tools.
They can be things like
provisioning.
They can be customer reference
management.
They can be all sorts
of things.
For schools, especially,
you can have
learning management systems.
So this means that, actually,
one of the really cool things
for me is, in this API, we
allow circles management.
So this means that, working
with Ocado, we've actually
developed a little cool script
that lets you pull data from
something like a file or Active
Directory or LDAP.
And you can actually look at
this hierarchical data and
turn it into circles.
So a new user can join a company
and start off with
teammates, managers, executives,
people that you
should be following, or your
local chefs because everyone
loves them, especially
here at Google.
Or even in school, you can
start, and you can have your
classmates circle ready to go.
THOR MITCHELL: As far as
stream integration is
concerned, there are a
couple of clear use
cases there as well.
One is, you might have an
existing CRM system or Content
Management System or some
other software that you
licensed from a third-party
enterprise software vendor.
And they might add functionality
to their tool
that allows that tool
to publish to the
stream on your behalf.
So for example, I want you to
meet a sales target or to
share your counter for
the day on Google+ or
something like that.
Another example is reporting
and auditing.
We have an example, a CloudLock,
that we mentioned
in the launch blog post, which
creates tools for helping you
understand your employees
are using
Google+ and other services.
JOANNA SMITH: So I think there
might be some confusion
regarding who can develop for
Google+ and for the Domains
API specifically.
Joel, do you want
to clarify that?
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Sure.
Anyone can develop.
The only thing is, in
order actually test,
using real API calls.
And to authenticate, you have
to be logged in to a real
Google Apps Domain account.
So if you try and make an
account which is not a Google
Apps Domains account, that
means things that, as you
might be familiar with Premier
or Standard, then you won't be
able to make these API
calls successfully.
JOANNA SMITH: All right.
Well, thanks so much for
joining us, you guys.
And I want to thank all of you
for joining and tuning in,
because this is a really
exciting new API,
totally brand new.
We announced it, like I said,
at I/O. But now it's finally
public, and I encourage
you to get started.
And once again, if you want to
learn what all we have to
offer, you can go to
developers.googl
e.com/+/domains.
Or if you want to just see some
code running already, you
can go to github.com/googleplus
and look
for the gplus-domains repos,
because those are the ones
that are going to have the
Domains quick starts.
And then, of course, you can
always ask your questions.
THOR MITCHELL: Yeah, so I
encourage you to join our
Google+ community called,
Developing with Google+.
If you want to discuss this
API with like-minded
developers.
We also have a Public Issue
track, search for Google+
Issue Tracker.
And that's where you can go to
request new features or report
any problems you might find.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: And for any
technical questions, you can
always submit them at
Stack Overflow.
Please be sure to use
the tag google-plus.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
So once again, thanks,
you guys.
And thank you to our product
managers for joining us today.
And right before we sign off, I
have one announcement, which
is, please don't freak out if
you don't see a "Google+
Developers Live" episode next
week or the week after.
We are planning something really
big in our brand new
series of episodes.
But we need some time to
finalize that and really make
sure that we're doing
a great job.
So we ask for your patience, as
we take a brief hiatus from
"Google+ Developers Live."
And on that note,
have a great week.